didn't want to get your thoughts on Kobe
Bryant because I know you posted about
him yesterday and of course all of us
feel like it's heartbreaking I just
don't even know if you can make sense
out of the senseless you know or how do
we I don't think we do I think with
every tragedy we're looking to measure
it based on our own faith that
everything's going to be okay that we're
always looked out for that there are
reasons things happen and and then we
have loss and heartbreak and we have no
idea how to trust or understand both the
heartbreak of his loss and his beautiful
amazing daughter and what that family
must be going through it's heavy on my
mind and heart I had the privilege of
knowing the family and and it's
devastating and we were here together at
this very event two years two years ago
and he was so proud to receive his Oscar
that night and you know I'm an LA native
and I'm an NBA fan so so heartbreaking
for this for everyone but for this city
to you know seeing so many people so
impacted did you hold your babies a
little tighter
everybody everybody does you know and
they had the privilege of knowing him
and their dad being friends with him
yeah we're all reeling in 2018 Kobe won
the Academy Award for best animated
short film for dear basketball love you
always
coley the Academy confirmed to ET that
they will honor Kobe during the Oscars
telecast on February 9